the Joe Rogan experience but that's like
like I said that people can look at my
act to be like he's talking about dicks
and [ __ ] I talk about all kinds of
things sometimes dicks and [ __ ] too
though yeah well those are funny disgust
well dicks and shits are funny often
yeah I have to like curb myself from
having um I got too many [ __ ] jokes now
this is like 12 minute you got I got a
few I got a chunk but it's funny it's
funny you know but it's sometimes you
just get on a run where that's what
you're interested in
yeah well also once you have a bit
that's working you want to extend it and
write other things about it so then
that's the way it goes I had a time
period where I had like four bits about
aliens yeah I was like goddamn this is
too much you almost once you get to a
certain point you stuck you're like what
can I just go all the way and just do a
one-man show about aliens right go to
Edinburgh yeah I'll just be the alien
guy yeah I bet you could you could be
like a like have a slide show behind you
yeah
SETI research the [ __ ] the big dish
that you see in the movie contact Jodie
Foster
yeah I'm not familiar with that movie
well I'm familiar with I never I wasn't
into it you didn't see that never been a
big alien guy no you're not a believer I
feel like this is the kind of place
where you could produce an alien really
good thing comes and rapes me well I
could show you the aliens but you're
gonna have to not be sober
oh are you you're fully sober guy yeah
did you suddenly a not sober guy yeah I
was a yeah were you a mess I mentally I
felt like a mess I mean I wasn't I never
killed anybody or anything but I was a
I'm an I'm an alcoholic yeah I [ __ ] in
the girl's shoe and yeah girl shoe what
would she do to you
nothing just invited me to stay at her
house I don't remember doing it I was in
a black but yeah I was all [ __ ] up and
then I woke up and I had to piss so bad
I just woke up in a the bed and I was
like I got a pant I was like let me I
don't know where I am I actually had a
flight I had a cross I was going to the
Seattle comedy competition
do you ever do that no it was like it's
like a month-long competition plats and
yeah and they call
Seattle but it's like actually all over
Washington State it's like a you drive
like three hours a night it's pretty
crazy really yeah but I had to like be
there the next day for a month
I'd like a 10:00 a.m. flight and I woke
up at like 9 20 in the morning and this
girl's bed and I was like I gotta get
the hell out of here but first I gotta
piss if I piss in this woman's bed it's
gonna be it's gonna be horrible so I ran
to the bathroom and found the bathroom
pissed for like a half hour you know
those and I'm trying to like put my [ __ ]
to get my I'm all [ __ ] up and then I
came out into like her living room and
her table had been like smashed like a
Chris Farley [ __ ] table and you're
that feeling when you're [ __ ] up weird
look at something and you're like that
was definitely me I need just feel like
I'm pretty sure I'm responsible for that
and then I was like I gotta go find my
clothes so I went back into her room and
on the way there I saw like kind of like
footprints of poo and then I came in and
she had a high-top Nike sneaker that
just had like a yeah and there was some
little pieces around and then there was
like a big puddle of urine to like I
didn't just because you never just [ __ ]
so I like pissed and [ __ ] but I got it
in her sneaker like no purpose
well I think I mean I was in a blackout
so but I think what happened was I
thought it was a toilet because I felt
like my sense of humor I'm not like I've
never been that gotta take a [ __ ]
places so I think I just saw a cylinder
well if it's dark it looks it's black
and it's a hole how big is her [ __ ]
shoes it's real big feet it was it was a
big woman no so I [ __ ] in there and then
what did went out did you lose contact
with her after this now it's Owens I was
like I gotta get out of here because I
got to go catch this flight so I took my
sock and put it on like a like a puppet
like a hand puppet a sock puppet and
just kind of pick it up that way I then
turned the sock inside out right which
like almost like a [ __ ] in the sock and
threw that away and I tried to wipe up
as much of the she asleep no no they're
gone oh my god I thought it's like 9:30
in the morning I thought I just went so
crazy that they all fled their own home
so then I get in the cab to go to the
airport missing my flight and I text the
girl and I was like I am so so I want to
kill myself like I can never do you tell
her that I sure know well I figured she
knew so she wrote back it's ok it was it
was crazy crazy night it was fun or
whatever and I was like man this girl
must [ __ ] party like she's just like
okay with me [ __ ]
I think this woman's wild so then I got
to the airport flew across the country
miss my flight I got the next flight out
on the plane I like cross my leg at one
point and realized I had [ __ ] like up my
pant leg it's like subtly put it down I
was had a middle seat for a full cuz I
miss minor outside of your pond outside
of my pen I [ __ ] just like a good streak
like I would say ankle Danny he didn't
go to the bathroom and try cleaning it
up no cuz I was already on the plane I
was in a middle seat and I it was like
caked on there oh my this is like hours
later oh my god so then I landed took
the plane Typhon off of airplane mode
and had a text that was like holy [ __ ]
we had no idea how bad it was and I was
like that makes more sense that is a
better reaction yeah cuz I thought they
must so the crazy part is I [ __ ] it was
like 9 in the morning they had let me
shorten it was your [ __ ] yeah they
didn't have a dog and I see they don't
just [ __ ] in their own shoes but then I
was late so I had to go straight to the
show and I ended up [ __ ] on your pants
yeah yeah I with [ __ ] on my pants and my
leg it was like cake to my leg hair and
it was the first no I don't think
anybody smelled it I don't think they
noticed cuz I think it would been I
don't know no one said anything so this
is fine because [ __ ] so then I finished
I took a shower finally like 12 hours
later I was actually I remember pulling
a little piece of [ __ ] out of my leg
hair it was the best shower of my life
it felt uh how was your set good I
killed and I ended up winning that night
because they each night you judged I
came in like first place it was like one
of the best sets I've ever had that
sounds like a real comedian show but
[ __ ] on your legs and you win a
competition but I [ __ ] kill I loved
it it was a pretty gory it was pretty
spot and then I
ended up sending this message to these
women I have the message it was on
Facebook so it lives forever but it's
about like this law it's like a
twelve-inch it just keeps going I'm like
I want to kill myself
I know this happened I really wanted to
die and they weren't luckily they were
like 22 they were like fresh out of
college so they were like pretty lol
forgiving yeah but they were in the 30s
I would send you a bunch of crying
emojis no they were just like laughing
yeah that's my favorite one so I sent
300 bucks in a called my friend Nate
bargatze and I was like how much is 300
bucks like a good amount and he's like
he's from Tennessee he's like I don't
think there's an amount you can do so I
sent him a card with 300 bucks and I
didn't really keep in touch with them
but they were they were nice and they're
like hopefully you don't get that [ __ ]
up again and then by the way I drank
that and I kept drinking for two more
you think that'd be like without him and
then I remember that night being like
well I'm gonna drink again at some point
as well so I drank for like two more
years then I got herpes I tried to stop
then too and then I just kept going [ __ ]
it
[Applause]